new and explosive developments tonight
surrounding hunter biden's hard drive
from hell
as peter schweitzer who's been reviewing
the materials
on the laptop he confirmed to me that
materials on that hard drive prove
joe biden was a direct beneficiary
of hunter's nefarious foreign dealings
now remember joe repeatedly said he had
no knowledge of hunter's dealings he
said it repeatedly i have no knowledge
whatsoever never once spoke to
to hunter about it but we have pictures
showing him
meeting with yep hunter's business
partners
we have emails showing hunter was
setting up meetings between
foreign business partners and his father
while he was vice president
and remember the revelations from tony
bobilinski came forward and said
that he met with joe biden and talked to
him about his business deals with hunter
joe is lying and while joe was vice
president this was all going on and it
doesn't stop there
because hunter's art dealings by the way
are still shrouded in secrecy
what is the market for these paintings
um doesn't look like great art to me who
are the buyers
why are they being kept secret is this
more influence peddling from the corrupt
biden syndicate business bureau anyway
remember there's still a cabal of deep
deep state bureaucrats inside the fbi
the same fbi that illegally spied on
president trump can we really expect any
serious thorough investigation
into the biden family crime syndicate
given what we know about the current
state of the fbi
here with reaction republican
congressman devin nunes
along with fox news contributor jason
chaffetz
devin let me start with you congressman
on this
question you're in the house intel
committee you know you're privy to
information
you would not be able to provide me or
even
congressman chaffetz um now
if somebody by the name of donald trump
jr or eric trump
got money from let's see russia and then
vladimir putin got a waiver on an
oil pipeline i'm just making this up as
i go and
as the same time trump was canceling the
keystone xl pipeline
and imagine if um let's say the 1.5
billion
deal was with one of the trump kids and
at the same time
our military bases were being threatened
by the communist chinese
and the reunification with taiwan was
being talked about
and you know if these things were
happening and if donald trump leveraged
a billion dollars to get a
prosecutor fired was investigating one
of the trump sons
i don't know i would imagine that
conflict of interest
investigations would begin uh would you
imagine the same
well sean that story sounds awfully
familiar i think that
this somebody actually did do that and i
think if you look at it the american
people are smart enough to know that if
this was any republican
this would be a massive political
scandal of one that we've
really never seen and don't forget right
before the election
this was supposedly russian
disinformation
it wasn't just biden who said that it
was over
50 top intelligence and military
officials who also said it
and i think at some at some point you
have to ask yourself
were these former officials and the
bidens in the biden campaign
were they colluding with russia were
they colluding with china
to help cover this up using the fake
news
and using the tech oligarchs who
censored this those are the types of
questions that
we need to continue to get out there to
the american people to expose
this corruption and what it really
amounts to i i believe that this really
swayed
the election because any type of scandal
like this would have been blowing up
beyond
belief before an election in october you
know i know your friends with them work
with
peter schweitzer jason chaffetz um
we now know that this hard drive exists
but yet nothing seems to be done about
it why
um because there's a bit of a cover-up
going on at the
at the moment remember now i'm a
distinguished fellow at the government
accountability institute i do work with
peter schweitzer but what he's done is
he's cross
cross referenced some of the data from
the hunter biden
laptop with the uh fbi or the uh secret
service records released by
uh senator johnson and another business
associate with hunter biden so they're
very careful about what they're looking
at here
but there is direct evidence that joe
biden himself
joe and jill biden took direct benefit
by using assets and things that were
purchased
based on the transactions that hunter
biden was involved and engaged with with
these foreign entities
and remember hunter biden has had
problems with russian prostitutes
he is under a tax investigation by the
federal government he admits that
he's had problems with guns uh he's had
trouble with drugs
he's taken money from the former mayor
of moscow's wife
and turned into tune of millions of
dollars
he has flown on air force two with one
of his business associates
how does a business associate of hunter
biden fly on air force two
to go to mexico city to set up a deal
you haven't heard the last of that
he's also flown on air force two to
china and then he has these ukraine
monies flowing in by the tens of
millions of dollars this is one of the
biggest
political scandals that we have ever
seen and it is being covered up by the
media it is not being investigated
and the fbi certainly is doing its part
to make sure that this information
doesn't get out the door
and where's john durham congressman
nunes i'll ask where he is but i'll
also ask where's adam schiff
well i don't really care where adam
schiff is right now i do care about john
durham
but sean the other question that we need
to ask is is to jason chaffetz you know
he served with me honorably he was
oversight chairman at one point
but i just don't understand why jason's
not in the art business because
i hear jason that you can get 500 000
bucks for you know i know you've never
been an artist like me
but this is another massive scandal so
to jason's
point this whole art deal if
anybody concocted this this would be
another
massive scandal nobody just gets out
from nowhere a lobbyist and
drug issues and all this and all of a
sudden it's like oh i've always wanted
to be an
artist let me just sell it for oh let's
say five hundred thousand dollars
yeah we're gonna i actually named it
portraits of a crack addict and
if it looks to me like finger painting
and
if i can do it it's not art trust me i
have no artistic ability
last word jason
uh there was recently a van gogh
painting that was discovered and
guess what it went up for auction for
150 000
it was only one-third the price of a
biden you can go get a biden
have access to the present united states
it's going to cost you three times more
but it's obviously worth a lot more than
any van gogh out there
sean of course it won't be made public
you know maybe
a russian oligarch a chinese national
the chinese military
a kazakhstan oligarch or maybe an
executive from barista holdings will
buy it who knows thank you both we
appreciate it hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else